the following is a conversation with
jaron lanier a computer scientist visual
artist philosopher writer futurist
musician and the founder of the field of
virtual reality to support this podcast
please check out our sponsors in the
description
as a side note you may know that jiren
is a staunch critic of social media
platforms him and i agree on many
aspects of this except perhaps i am more
optimistic about it being possible to
build better platforms and better
artificial intelligence systems that put
long-term interests and happiness of
human beings first
let me also say a general comment about
these conversations
i try to make sure i prepare well remove
my ego from the picture and focus on
making the other person shine as we try
to explore the most beautiful and
insightful ideas in their mind
this can be challenging when the ideas
that are close to my heart are being
criticized
in those cases i do offer a little
pushback but respectfully and then move
on trying to have the other person come
out looking wiser in the exchange
i think there's no such thing as winning
in conversations nor in life
my goal is to learn and to have fun
i ask that you don't see my approach to
these conversations as weakness it is
not
it is my attempt at showing respect and
love for the other person
that said i also often just do a bad job
of talking but you probably already knew
that so please give me a pass on that as
well
this is the lex friedman podcast and
here is my conversation with jaron
lanier
you're considered the founding father of
virtual reality
do you think we will one day spend most
or all of our lives in uh virtual
reality worlds
i have always found the very most
valuable moment in virtuality to be the
moment when you take off the headset and
your senses are refreshed and you
perceive physicality
uh afresh you know as if you were a
newborn baby but
with a little more experience so you can
really notice just how incredibly
strange and
delicate and peculiar and impossible the
real world is
um
so the magic is and perhaps forever will
be in the physical world
well that's my take on it that's just me
i mean i think i don't get to tell
everybody else how to think or how to
experience virtuality and at this point
there have been multiple generations of
younger people
who've
come along and liberated me from having
to worry about these things
uh but i i should say also even in
what some well i called it mixed reality
back in the day and these days it's
called augmented reality uh but with
something like a hololens even then
like one of my favorite things is to
augment a forest not because i think the
forest needs augmentation but when you
look at
the augmentation next to a real tree the
real tree just pops out as being
astounding you know it's
it's
interactive it's changing slightly all
the time if you pay attention and it's
hard to pay attention to that but when
you compare it to virtual reality all of
a sudden you do
and even in practical applications uh my
my favorite
early application of virtuality which we
prototyped going back to the 80s when i
was working with dr joe rosen at
stanford med near near where we are now
we made the first surgical simulator
and
to go from
the fake anatomy of the simulation which
is incredibly valuable for many things
for designing procedures for training
for all kinds of things then to go to
the real person
boy it's really something like uh
surgeons really get woken up by that
transition it's very cool so i think the
transition is actually more valuable
than the simulation
that's fascinating i never
really thought about that it's almost
it's like traveling elsewhere in the
physical space can help you appreciate
how much you
value your home once you return
well that's how i take it i mean
once again people have different
attitudes towards it
all are welcome what do you think is the
difference between the virtual world and
the physical meat space world that
that you are still drawn for you
personally still drawn to the physical
world
like there clearly then is a distinction
is there some fundamental distinction or
is it the peculiarities of the current
set of technology
in terms of the kind of virtuality that
we have now
uh it's made of software and software is
terrible stuff yeah software
is always the slave of its own history
its own legacy
it's always um infinitely arbitrarily
messy and arbitrary working with it
brings out a certain kind of nerdy
personality in people or at least in me
which um i'm not that fond of and there
are all kinds of things about software i
don't like
and so that's different from the
physical world
it's not something we understand as you
just pointed out on the other hand you
know i'm a little mystified when people
ask me well do you think the universe is
a computer
and i have to say well i mean
what on earth could you possibly mean if
you say it isn't a computer if it isn't
a computer
it
wouldn't
follow principles consistently and it
wouldn't be intelligible because what
else is a computer ultimately you know i
mean and we have physics we have
technology you know so we can do
technology so we can program it so i
mean of course it's some kind of
computer but
i think trying to understand it as a
turing machine is probably
a foolish approach
right that's the question whether
it performs this computer we call the
universe performs the kind of
computation that can be modeled as a
universal touring machine or is it
something much more fancy
so fancy in fact that we it may be
beyond our cognitive capabilities to
understand
turing machines are kind of
um
i'd call them teases in a way
because like
if you have
an infinitely smart programmer with an
infinite amount of time an infinite
amount of memory and an infinite clock
speed
then they're universal but yeah that
cannot exist so they're not universal in
practice and they they actually are
in practice a very particular sort of
machine within
you know the constraints within
the conservation principles of any
reality that's
worth being in probably and so
so i i
uh
i think
the universality of a particular model
is probably a deceptive way to think
even though at some sort of limit of
course it's can it
something like that's got to be true at
some sort of
high enough limit but it's just not
accessible to us so what's the point
well to me the question of like whether
we're living inside a computer or a
simulation is interesting in the
following way
there's a technical question is here
how difficult is it to build
a machine
not that simulates the universe
but that makes it sufficiently realistic
that we wouldn't know the difference or
better yet
sufficiently realistic that we would
kind of know the difference but we would
prefer to stay in the virtual world
anyway
i want to give you a few different
answers i want to give you the one that
i think has the most practical
importance to human beings right now
which is that
there's a kind of an assertion sort of
built into the way the questions usually
ask that i think is false which which is
a suggestion that people have a fixed
level of ability to perceive reality in
in a given way and actually
people are always
learning evolving forming themselves
we're fluid too we're also
programmable self-programmable
changing adapting and so
uh
my favorite way to get at this is to
talk about the history of other media so
for instance there was a peer review
paper that showed that an early wire
recorder playing back an opera singer
behind a curtain was indistinguishable
from a real opera singer and so now of
course to us it would not only be
distinguishable but it would be very
blatant because the the recording would
be horrible but to the people at the
time without the experience of it it
seemed plausible
there was an early demonstration of
extremely crude video teleconferencing
between new york and dc
in the 30s i think so that people viewed
as being absolutely realistic and
indistinguishable which to us would be
horrible
uh and there are many other examples
another one one of my favorite ones is
in the civil war era
there were itinerant photographers who
collected photographs of people who just
looked kind of like a few archetypes
so you could buy a photo of somebody who
looked kind of like your loved one
to remind you of that person because
actually photographing them was
inconceivable and hiring a painter was
too expensive and you didn't have any
way for the painter to represent them
remotely anyway how would they even know
what they looked like
so these are all great examples of how
in the early days of different media we
perceived the media as being really
great but then we evolved through the
experience of the media this gets back
to what i was saying maybe the greatest
gift of photography is that we can see
the flaws in a photograph and appreciate
reality more
maybe the greatest gift of audio
recording is that we can distinguish
that opera thing on our singer now from
that recording of the opera singer on
the horrible wire recorder so so we're
we we shouldn't limit ourselves by some
assumption of stasis that's incorrect
so that's the first thing that's my
first answer which is i think the most
important one now of course somebody
might come back and say oh but you know
technology can go so far there must be
some point at which would surpass that's
a different question i i think that's
also an interesting question but i think
the answer i just gave you is actually
the more important answer to the more
important question that's profound yeah
but can you can you
the second question which you're now
making me realize is way different
is it possible to create worlds in which
people would want to stay
instead of the real world well
like um i unmask like large numbers of
numbers of people uh what i hope is you
know as i said before i hope that the
experience of virtual worlds helps
people appreciate
this this physical world we have and
feel
tender towards it and and uh
keep it from getting too [ __ ] up
that's my hope
um do you see all technology in that way
so basically technology
helps us appreciate
the more sort of
technology-free aspect of life
well
media technology
you know i mean i i you can stretch that
i mean you can
let me say i could definitely play
mcluhan and turn this into a general
theory it's totally doable the program
you just described is totally doable
um in fact i will psychically predict
that if you did the research you could
find 20 phd theses that do that already
yeah i don't i don't know but they might
exist but
i i don't know how much value there is
in pushing
a particular
idea that far
claiming that reality isn't a computer
in some sense seems incoherent to me
because we have we can program it we
have technology it has it seems to obey
physical laws what more do you want from
it to be a computer i mean it's a
computer of some kind we don't know
exactly what kind we might not know how
to think about it we're working on it
but uh sorry to interrupt but you're
absolutely right like that's my
fascination with the ai as well
is it uh helps in the case of ai
i see it as a set of techniques that
help us understand ourselves understand
us humans in the same way virtual
reality
and you're putting it brilliantly which
it's a it's a way to help us understand
reality
sure appreciate and open our eyes more
richly to reality
that's that's certainly how i see it and
i
i wish people who become incredibly
fascinated who go down the rabbit hole
of uh the different fascinations with
whether we're in a simulation or not or
you know that there's a whole world of
variations on that um
i wish they'd step back and think about
their own motivations and exactly what
they mean you know what and and i think
the danger with these things
is
um
so if you say is the universe some kind
of computer broadly it has to be because
it's not coherent to say that the uh
that it isn't on the other hand to say
that that means you know anything about
what kind of computer
that's something very different and the
same thing is true for the brain the
same thing is true for
anything where you might use
computational metaphors like we have to
have a bit of modesty about where we
stand and the problem i have with these
framings of computation as these
ultimate cosmic questions is that it has
a way of getting people to pretend they
know more than they do can you maybe um
this is a therapy session psychoanalyze
me for a second
i really like the elder scrolls series
it's a role-playing game
uh skyrim for example why do i enjoy
so deeply just walking around that world
and then there's people you could talk
to
and you can
just like it's an escape but you know my
my life is awesome i'm truly happy but i
also am happy with the with the music
that's playing and the and the mountains
and
uh carrying around a sword and just
that
i don't know what that is it's very
pleasant though to go there and i miss
it sometimes
i think it's
wonderful
to love
artistic creations it's wonderful to
love
contact with other people it's wonderful
to love play and ongoing evolving
meaning and patterns with other people i
think it's uh it's a good thing
you know
i'm not i'm not like anti-tech and i'm
certainly not anti digital tech i'm anti
as everybody knows by now i think the
you know
manipulative economy of social media is
making everybody nuts and all that so
i'm anti that stuff but the core of it
of course i worked for many many years
on trying to make that stuff happen
because i think it can be beautiful like
i
um i don't like why not
you know and and by the way
um there's a thing about humans which is
um
uh we're problematic any
any kind of social interaction with
other people is gonna have its problems
people are political and tricky and like
i love classical music but when you
actually go to a classical music thing
and it turns out oh actually this is
like a backroom power deal kind of place
and a big status ritual as well
and that's kind of
not as fun
that's part of the package and the thing
is it's always going to be there's
always going to be a mix of things
um
i i don't uh i don't think the search
for purity is going to get you anywhere
so i'm not worried about that i worry
about the the really bad cases where
we're becoming where we're making
ourselves crazy or cruel enough that we
might not survive and i think you know
the social media criticism
rises to that level but i'm glad you
enjoyed it i think it's great
and i like that you basically say that
every experience has both beauty and
darkness as in with classical music i
also play classical piano so i
appreciate it very much but it's
interesting i mean every and even the
darkness a man's search for meaning with
victor franco and uh
in concentration camps
even there there's opportunity to
discover beauty
now
and so it's
that's that's the interesting thing
about humans is the capacity to discover
uh beautiful in the darkest of moments
but there's always
the dark parts too well i mean it's
our situation is structurally difficult
we are
um
actually no it is it's true we perceive
socially we depend on each other for our
sense of
place and and perception of the world i
mean we're dependent on each other and
yet there's also a degree in which we're
inevitably
um
we never really let each other down uh
we are set up to be competitive as well
as supportive i mean it's a it's just
our fundamental situation is complicated
and challenging
and i wouldn't have it any other way
okay let's talk about one of the most
challenging things
one of the things i unfortunately am
very afraid of
being human
allegedly
you wrote an essay on death and
consciousness in which you write a note
certainly the fear of death has been one
of the greatest driving forces in the
history of thought and in the formation
of the character of civilization and yet
it is under acknowledged the great book
on the subject the denial of death by
ernest becker deserves a reconsideration
i'm russian so i have to ask you about
this what's the role of death and life
see
you would have enjoyed coming to our
house because uh
my wife is russian and we also have we
have a piano of such spectacular
qualities you wouldn't
you would have freaked out
but anyway we'll let all that go
so
the context in which i remember that
essay uh sort of this was from maybe the
90s or something and um
i used to publish in a journal called
the journal of consciousness studies
because i was i was interested in these
endless debates about consciousness and
science
which
certainly continued today
and
i was
interested in how
the fear of death
and the denial of death played into
different philosophical approaches to
consciousness
because
i uh i think on the one hand
uh
this sort of
sentimental
school of dualism meaning the feeling
that there's something apart from the
physical brain some kind of soul or
something else
is obviously motivated in a sense by a
hope that that whatever whatever that is
will survive death and continue and
that's a
very core aspect of a lot of the world
religions not all of them not not really
but you know uh most of them
um
the
thing i noticed is that the the opposite
of those which might be the sort of
hardcore no the brain's a computer and
that's it
in a sense
we're
motivated in the same way with a
remarkably similar chain of of uh of
arguments which is
no i the brain's a computer and i'm
going to figure it out in my lifetime
and upload it upload myself and i'll
live forever
that's interesting yeah that's that's
like the implied thought right yeah and
so it's kind of this in a funny way it's
it's the same thing
it's uh
um
it's peculiar
that you to notice that these people who
would appear to be opposites in
character and cultural references and uh
uh and in their ideas actually are
remarkably similar
and and to to to an incredible degree
this sort of hardcore uh
computationalist idea about uh the brain
has turned into medieval christianity
with together like there's a they're the
people who are afraid that if you have
the wrong thought you'll piss off the
super ais of the future who will come
back and zap you
and and all that stuff yeah it's like
it's really it's really turned into
medieval christianity all over again uh
this is so the ernest becker's idea that
death
the fear of death is the warm at the
core
which is like
that's the that's the core motivator of
everything we see humans have created
the question is if that fear of
mortality is somehow core it's like a
prerequisite
so
what you just you just moved across this
vast cultural chasm
uh that separates me from most of my
colleagues in a way and i can't answer
what you just said on the level without
this huge deconstruction yes should i do
it yes what's the chasm okay
let us travel across this vessel okay i
don't believe in ai i don't think
there's any ai there's just algorithms
we make them we control them now
they're tools they're not creatures now
this is something that rubs a lot of
people the wrong way
and don't i know it when i was young my
main mentor was marvin minsky who's the
principal author of
the computer as creature
rhetoric that we still use
uh he was the first person to have the
idea at all but he certainly
populated
the ai culture with most of its tropes i
would say
because a lot of stuff people will say
oh did you hear this new idea about ai
and i'm like yeah i heard it in 1978
sure yeah i remember that
so marvin was really the person and uh
marvin and i used to argue
all the time about the stuff because i
always rejected it and of all of his
um
of all of his uh i wasn't formally his
student but i worked for him as a
researcher but
of of all of his students and
student-like people
of his young adoptees
um
i think i was the one who argued with
him about this stuff in particular and
he loved it because yeah i would have
loved to hear that conversation it was
fun did you ever converse to a place
oh no no so the very last time i saw him
he was quite frail and and uh
i was in uh in boston and i was going to
the old house in brookline his amazing
house
and one of our mutual friends said hey
listen marvin's so frail
don't do the argument with him don't
argue about ai
you know and so i said but marvin loves
that and so i showed up and he's like he
was frail he looked up and he said
are you ready to argue
he's such an amazing person
so um
it's hard to summarize this because it's
decades of stuff
the first thing to say
is that nobody can claim absolute
knowledge about whether
somebody or something else is conscious
or not
this is all a matter of faith and in
fact
um
i think the whole idea of faith needs to
be updated so it's not about god but
it's just about stuff in the universe we
we have faith in each other being
conscious and then um
i used to frame this as a thing called
the circle of empathy
in my old papers and then
um
it turned into a thing for the animal
rights movement so i noticed peter
singer using it i don't know if it was
coincident or but anyway we there's this
idea that you draw a circle around
yourself and the stuff inside is more
like you might be conscious might be
deserving of your empathy of your
consideration and the stuff outside the
circle isn't and
um outside the circle might be a rock
or
i don't know uh so uh and that circle is
fundamentally based on faith
well your faith and what is and what
isn't the thing about this circle
is it can't be pure faith it also has
it's also a pragmatic decision and this
is where things get complicated
if you try to make it too big you suffer
from incompetence
if you say
i don't want to kill a bacteria i will
not brush my teeth i don't know like
what do you do yeah like you know like
there's a there's a competence question
where you do have to draw the line
people who make it too small become
cruel
people are so clanished and political
and so worried about themselves ending
up on the bottom
of society that they are always ready to
gang up on some designated group and so
there's always these people who are
being tried we're always trying to shove
somebody out of the circle
and so aren't you shoving ai outside the
circle well give me a second all right
so so there's a pragmatic consideration
here yeah and so uh and and uh the the
biggest questions are probably fetuses
and animals lately but ai is getting
there
now with ai
i think
uh
and i've had this discussion so many
times people say but aren't you afraid
if you exclude ai you'd be cruel to some
consciousness
and then i would say well if you include
ai
you make yourself
you you exclude yourself from being able
to be a good engineer or designer and so
you're facing incompetence immediately
so like i really think we need to
subordinate algorithms and be much more
skeptical of them
your intuition you speak about this
brilliantly with social media how things
can go wrong
isn't it
possible
uh
to design systems that that show
compassion not to manipulate you but
give you control
and make your life better if you so
choose to like grow together with
systems and the way we grow with dogs
and cats with pets with significant
others in that way they grow to become
better people
i i don't understand why that's
fundamentally not possible you're saying
oftentimes
you get into trouble
by thinking you know what's good for
people look
there's this question of what framework
we're speaking in um do you know who
alan watts was
so alan watts once said
morality is like gravity that in some
absolute cosmic sense there can't be
morality because at some point it all
becomes relative and who are we anyway
like morality is relative to us tiny
creatures
but
here on earth
we're with each other this is our frame
and morality is a very real thing same
thing with gravity at some point you
know you get
you get into interstellar space and you
might not feel much of it but here we
are on earth and and i think in the same
sense um
i think this
this identification
with a frame that's quite remote
cannot be separated
from a feeling of wanting to feel sort
of separate separate from and superior
to other people or something like that
there's there's an impulse behind it
that i really have to reject
and
we're just not competent yet to talk
about these kinds of absolutes
okay so i agree with you that a lot of
technologists sort of lack this basic
respect uh understanding and love for
humanity there's a separation there the
thing i'd like to push back against it's
not that you disagree but i believe you
can create technologies and you can
create a new kind of technologist
engineer that does build systems that
respect humanity not just respect but
admire humanity that have empathy for
common humans have compassion
i mean no no no i i think
yeah i mean i think musical instruments
are a great example of that musical
instruments are technologies that help
people connect in fantastic ways and
that's uh
a great example um
my uh
my invention or design during the
pandemic period was this thing called
together mode where people see
themselves seated sort of in a a
classroom or a theater instead of in
squares and
it allows them to
semi-consciously perform to each other
as if they're
as if they have proper eye contact as if
they're paying attention to each other
non-verbally and weirdly that turns out
to work
and so it promotes empathy so far as i
can tell i hope i hope it is of some use
to somebody
uh
the ai idea isn't really new um i would
say it was born with adam smith's
invisible hand with this idea that we
build this algorithmic thing and it gets
a bit beyond us and then we think it
must be smarter than us and the thing
about the invisible hand is absolutely
everybody has some line they draw where
they say no no no we're going to take
control of this thing they might have
different lines they might care about
different things but everybody
ultimately became a keynesian because it
just didn't work it really wasn't that
smart it was sometimes smart and
sometimes it failed you know and and and
so if you really you know people who
really really really
want to believe in the invisible hand is
infinitely smart
screw up their economies terribly you
have to you know you have to recognize
the economy as a subservient tool
everybody does when it's to their
advantage they might not when it's not
to their advantage that's kind of an
interesting game that happens
but the thing is it's just like that
with our algorithms you know like uh
you you can uh you can have a sort of a
chicago you cannot you know economic
philosophy about your computer say no no
no my things come alive it's smarter
than anything
i think that there is a deep loneliness
within all of us this is what we seek we
seek love from each other
i think ai can help us connect deeper
like this this is what you criticize
social media for i think there's much
better ways of doing social media that
doesn't lead to manipulation but instead
released a deeper connection between
humans leads to you becoming a better
human being and what that requires is
some agency on the part of ai to to be
almost like a therapist i mean a
companion
it's not telling you
what's right it's not guiding you as if
it's an all-knowing thing
it's just another companion that you can
leave at any time
you you have complete transparency
control over there's a lot of mechanisms
that you can have that that are counter
to how current social media uh operates
that i think
is subservient to humans or no
deeply respects
human beings
and it's empathetic to their experience
and all those kinds of things i think
it's possible to create ai systems like
that and i think they i mean that's a
technical discussion of whether they
need to have
something that looks like more like ai
versus algorithms something that has a
identity something that has a
personality all those kinds of things ai
systems and you've spoken extensively
how ai systems
manipulate you within social networks
and that's the biggest the biggest
problem isn't necessarily that
um
there's advertisement that uh
you know social networks present you
with advertisements that then get you to
buy stuff that's not the biggest problem
the biggest problem is they then
manipulate you
your they alter like your
human nature to get you to buy stuff or
or to get you to um
do whatever the advertiser wants or
maybe you can correct yeah i i don't see
it quite that way but we can work with
that as an approximation sure so my i
think the actual thing is even sort of
more ridiculous and stupider than that
but that's that's okay let's let's so my
question is let's not use the word ai
uh but
how do we
fix it oh fixing social media um
that diverts us into this whole other
field in my view which is economics
which i always thought was really boring
but we have no choice but to turn into
economists if we want to fix this
problem because it's all about
incentives but um
i've been around this thing since it
started and and uh i've been in the
meetings where the social media
companies
sell themselves to the people who put
the most money into them which are
usually the big advertising holding
companies and whatnot and there's this
there's this idea that i think is kind
of a fiction
and maybe it's even
been recognized as that by everybody
that
the the algorithm will get really good
at getting people to buy something
because i think people have looked at
their returns and looked at what happens
and everybody recognizes that's not
exactly right it's more
like a cognitive access
blackmail payment at this point
like you just to be connected you're
paying the money it's not so much that
the persuasion algorithms that so
stanford renamed its program but it used
to be called engage persuade the engaged
part works the persuade part is iffy but
the thing is that
once people are engaged in order for you
to exist as a business in order for you
to be known at all you have to put money
in
it's a giant it's a giant cognitive
access blackmail scheme at this point so
um because the science behind the
persuade part it's not entirely
it's not entirely uh a failure but it's
it's not what the there's we play make
believe that it it works more than it
does um the damage doesn't come honestly
as i've i've said in my books i'm not
anti-advertising i actually think
advertising can be demeaning and
annoying and banal
and ridiculous
and take up a lot of our time with
stupid stuff like there's a lot of ways
to criticize that um advertising that's
accurate and it can also lie and all
kinds of things however
if i look at the biggest picture i think
advertising
at least as it was understood before
social media
helped bring people into modernity in a
way that overall
actually did benefit people overall
and
you might say am i contradicting myself
because i was saying you should
manipulate people yeah i am probably
here i mean i'm not i'm not pretending
to have this perfect airtight
world view without some contradictions i
think there's a bit of a contradiction
there so you know well looking at the
long arc of history advertisement has as
in some parts benefited society yeah
because it funded some efforts that
perhaps yeah i mean i think like there's
a there's a thing where
uh sometimes i think it's actually been
of some use
now
let's
where the damage comes is a different
thing though social media
um algorithms on social media have to
work on feedback loops where they
present you with stimulus they have to
see if you respond to the stimulus
now the the problem is that the the
measurement mechanism for telling if you
respond in the engagement
feedback loop is very very crude it's
things like whether you click more or
occasionally if you're staring at the
screen more if there's a forward-facing
camera that's activated but typically
there isn't
so you have this incredibly crude back
channel of information
and so it's crude enough that it only
catches
sort of the more dramatic responses from
you and those are the fight-or-flight
responses those are the things where you
get scared or pissed off or aggressive
or horny you know these are these
ancient the sort of what are sometimes
called the lizard brain circuits or
whatever you know these these fast
response old old old evolutionary
business
circuits that we have that
are helpful in survival once in a while
but are not us at our best they're not
who we want to be they're not how we
relate to each other they're this old
business but it's so then just when
you're engaged using those intrinsically
totally aside from whatever the topic is
you start to get incrementally just a
little bit more paranoid xenophobic
aggressive
you know you get a little stupid and
like a you become a jerk
and it happens slowly it happens it's
not it's not like everybody's like
instantly transformed but it does kind
of happen progressively where people who
get hooked kind of get drawn more and
more into this pattern of being at their
worst would you say that people are able
to when they get hooked in this way look
back at themselves from 30 days ago and
say
i am less happy
with who i am now or i'm not happy with
who i am now versus who i was 30 days
ago are they able to self-reflect when
you take yourself outside of the lizard
brain sometimes um i wrote a book about
people
suggesting people take a break from
their social media to see what happens
and maybe even
it was actually the title of the book
was just the arguments to delete your
account yeah
and 10 arguments 10 arguments although i
always said i don't know that you should
i can give you the arguments it's up to
you i'm always very clear about that but
you know i get like i don't have a
social media account obviously and
it's not that easy for people to reach
me they have to search out an
old-fashioned email address on a super
crappy antiquated website like it's it's
actually a bit i don't make it easy and
even with that i get this huge flood of
mail from people who say oh i quit my
social media i'm doing so much better i
can't believe how bad it was
but the thing is what's for me a huge
flood of mail would be an imperceptible
trickle from the perspective of facebook
right and so uh i think it's rare for
somebody to look at themselves and say
oh boy i sure screwed myself over
well it's a really hard thing to ask of
somebody none of us find that easy right
well the reason that's hard the reason i
ask this is is it possible to design
social media
systems that optimize for some longer
term metrics of
you huge being happy with yourself
personal i don't think you should try to
engineer personal growth or happiness i
think what you should do is design a
system that's just respectful of the
people and subordinates itself to the
people and doesn't have perverse
incentives and then at least there's a
chance of something decent happening you
have to recommend stuff right so but so
you're saying like be respect what does
that actually mean engineering-wise like
people yeah curation people have to
people have to be responsible algorithms
shouldn't be recommending algorithms
don't understand enough to recommend
algorithms are crap in this era i mean
i'm sorry they are like i and i'm not
saying this as somebody as a critic from
the outside i'm in the middle of it i
know what they can do i know the math i
know what the corpora are
i'm
you know i know the best ones
our office is funding gpt3 and all these
things that are that are you know
at the at the edge of what's possible
and they do not have
yet
i mean it still is
statistical emergent pseudosemantics it
doesn't actually have deep
representation emerging of anything it's
just not like i mean that i'm speaking
the truth here and you know it well
let me push back on this this uh there's
several truths here so one you're
speaking to the way certain companies
operate currently
i don't think it's outside the realm of
what's technically uh feasible to do
they're just not incentive like
companies are not why fix this thing
i am aware
that for example the youtube search and
discovery has been very helpful to me
and there's a huge number of there's so
many videos that it's nice to have a
little bit of help have you done but i'm
still in control let me ask you
something have you done the experiment
of letting youtube recommend videos to
you either starting from
a absolutely anonymous random place
where it doesn't know who you are or
from knowing who you or somebody else is
and then going 15 or 20 hops have you
ever done that and just let it go
top video recommend and then just go 20
hops no i know i've done that many times
now
i have because of how large youtube is
and how widely it's used it's very hard
to get to enough scale to get a
statistically
solid result on this i've done it with
high school kids with dozens of kids
doing it at a time
every time i've done an experiment the
majority of times after about 17 or 18
hops you end up in really weird paranoid
bizarre territory because ultimately
that is the stuff the algorithm rewards
the most because of the feedback
crudeness i was just talking about
so uh i'm not saying that the video
never recommends something cool i'm
saying that it's fundamental core is one
that promotes a paranoid style that
promotes increasing irritability that
promotes xenophobia promotes fear anger
promotes selfishness promotes separation
between people
uh and i would encoura the thing is it's
very hard to do this work solidly many
have repeated this experiment and yet it
still is kind of anecdotal i'd like to
do like a large you know citizen science
thing sometime and do it but then i
think the problem with that is youtube
would detect it and then change it yes i
definitely say i love that kind of stuff
on twit so jack dorsey has spoken about
uh
doing healthy conversations on twitter
or optimizing for healthy conversations
what that requires within twitter are
most likely
citizen experiments of what does how the
conversation actually look like and what
how do you incentivize those healthy
conversations you're describing what
often happens and what is currently
happening what i'd like to argue is it's
possible to strive for healthy
conversations not in a dogmatic way of
saying
uh i know what healthy conversations are
and i will tell you i think one way to
do this is to try to look around at
social
maybe not things that are officially
social media but things where people are
together online and see which ones have
more healthy conversations even if it's
hard to
be completely objective in that
measurement you can kind of at least
cruelly you could do subjective
annotation of this like having so here
crowdsourced yeah one that i've been
really interested in is github
because um
uh it could change i'm not saying it'll
always be but for the most part github
has had a relatively quite low poison
quotient
and
i think there's a few things about
github that are interesting
one thing about it is that people have a
stake in it it's not just empty status
games there's actual code or there's
actual stuff being done and i think as
soon as you have a real world stake in
something
you have a motivation to not screw up
that thing and i think that that's often
missing that there's a there's no
incentive for the person to really
preserve something if they if they get a
little bit of attention from um dumping
on somebody's tick tock or something
that there's they don't pay any price
for it but on you have to kind of
get decent with people when you have a
shared stake you know a little secret so
get so github does a bit of that um
github was wonderful yes but i yeah i'm
tempted to play
uh the gerund back at you which is that
so github is currently is amazing but
the thing is if you have a stake then if
it's a social media platform they can
use the fact that you have a steak to
manipulate you because you want to
preserve the steak so like
right well this is why this all right
this gets us into the economics so
there's this thing called data dignity
that i've been studying for a long time
i wrote a book about an earlier version
of it called who owns the future
um and the the basic idea of it is that
once again this is the third year
conversation the fascinating topic let
me do the fastest version of this i can
do the fastest way i know how to do this
is to compare two features
all right
so
future one is then the normative one the
one we're building right now and future
two is going to be data dignity okay and
um and i'm gonna use a particular
population i live on the hill and
berkeley and one of the features about
the hill is that as the climate changes
we might burn down and i'll lose our
houses or die or something like it's
it's dangerous you know and it didn't
used to be
and so um who keeps us alive well the
city does the city does some things the
electric company kind of sort of maybe
hopefully better
individual people who own property take
care of their property that's all nice
but there's this other middle layer
which is fascinating to me
which is that the groundskeepers
who work up and down that hill many of
whom are not
legally here many of whom don't speak
english
cooperate with each other
to make sure trees don't touch to
transfer fire easily from la to lot they
have this whole little web that's
keeping us safe i didn't know about this
at first i just started talking to them
because they were out there during the
pandemic and so i try to just see who
are these people who are these people
who are keeping us alive
now i want to talk about the two
different faiths for those people under
future one and future two
future one um
some weird like kindergarten paint job
van with all these like cameras and
where things drives up observes what the
gardeners and groundskeepers are doing
a few years later some amazing robots
that can shimmy up trees and all this
show up all those people are out of work
and there are these robots doing the
thing and the robots are good and they
can scale to more land and they're
actually good but then they're all these
people out of work and these people have
lost dignity they don't know what
they're going to do
and and then somebody say well they go
on basic income whatever they become
wards of the state
my problem with that solution is every
time in history that you've had some
centralized thing that's stoling out the
benefits that things get seized by
people because it's too centralized and
it gets seized that's happened to every
communist experiment i can find
um so i think that turns into a poor
future that will be unstable i don't
think people will feel good in it i
think it'll be a political disaster with
the sequence of people seizing this
central source of the the basic income
and you'll say oh no an algorithm can do
it then people will seize the algorithm
they'll see they'll seize control unless
the algorithm is decentralized and it's
impossible to cease to control yeah but
but uh
60 something people own a quarter of all
the bitcoin like like the things that we
think are decentralized are not
decentralized
so let's go to future two future two
the gardeners see that that van with all
the cameras and the kindergarten paint
job and they say with the groundskeepers
and they say hey the robots are coming
we're gonna form a data union and
amazingly california has a little baby
data union law emerging in the books yes
and so there's and so they'll um and and
what they say they say we're gonna form
we're gonna form a data union and we're
gonna
not only are we gonna sell our data to
this place but we're going to make it
better than it would have been if they
were just grabbing it without our
cooperation and we're going to improve
it we're going to make the robots more
effective we're going to make them
better and we're going to be proud of it
we're going to become a new class of
experts that are respected and then
here's the interesting
there's two things that are different
about that world
from future one one thing of course the
people have more pride they have more
sense
of of ownership of uh of of of agency
but
what the robots do changes uh instead of
just like this functional like we'll
figure out how to keep the neighborhood
from burning down uh
you have this whole creative community
that wasn't there before thinking well
how can we make these robots better so
we can keep on earning money there'll be
waves of
creative
uh groundskeeping with spiral pumping
pumpkin patches and waves of cultural
things there'll be new ideas like wow i
wonder if we could do something about
climate change mitigation with how we do
this what about what about fresh water
can we what about can we make the food
healthier what about what about all of a
sudden there'll be this whole creative
community on the case
and isn't it nicer to have a high-tech
future with more creative classes than
one with more dependent classes isn't
that a better future but but but
future one and future two
have the same robots and the same
algorithms there's no technological
difference there's only a human
difference yeah
and that second future too that's state
of dignity
the economy that you're i mean the game
theory here is on the humans and then
the technology is just the tools that
enable yeah you know i mean i think you
can believe in ai and be in future too i
just think it's a little harder you have
to do you have to do more
um contortions it's possible so in the
case of social media
what is uh idea dignity look like is it
people getting paid for their data yeah
i think um what should happen is in the
future there should be uh massive data
unions uh
for people putting
content into the system and the state
unions smooth out the results a little
bit so it's not winner take all but at
the same time
and people have to pay for it too they
have to pay for
facebook the way they pay for netflix
with with an allowance for the poor
there has to be a there has to be a way
out too but the thing is people do pay
for netflix it's a going concern
people pay for xbox and playstation like
people there's enough people to pay for
stuff they want this could happen too
it's just that this precedence started
that moved in the wrong direction and
then what has to happen
the economy is a measuring device if
it's an
honest measuring device
the outcomes for people form a normal
distribution a bell curve and then so
there should be a few people who do
really well a lot of people who do okay
and then we should have an expanding
economy reflecting more and more
creativity and expertise flowing through
the network and that expanding economy
moves the result just a bit forward so
more people are getting money out of it
than are putting money into it so it
gradually expands the economy and lifts
all boats and the in the society has to
support
the the the lower wing of the bell curve
too but not universal basic income it
has to be
for the you know because if it's an
honest if it's an honest economy there
will be
uh that lower wing and we we have to
support those people there has to be a
safety net um but um see what i believe
i'm not going to talk about ai but i
will say
that i think there'll be more and more
algorithms that are useful and so i
don't think everybody's going to be
supplying data to grounds keeping robots
nor do i think everybody's going to make
their living with tick-tock videos i
think in both cases there'll be a rather
small contingent
that do well enough at either of those
things but i think there might be many
many many many of those niches that
start to evolve as they're more and more
algorithms more and more robots and it's
that large number
that will create the economic potential
for a very large part of society to
become members of new creative classes
do you think it's possible to
um
to create a social network that competes
with twitter and facebook that's large
and centralized in this way not
centralized or large large how do we get
all right so i gotta tell you how to get
from what i'm talking how to get from
where we are to anything kind of in the
zone of what i'm talking about is
challenging
um
i know some of the people who run like i
know jack dorsey and i view jack
as somebody
who's actually
i think he's really striving and
searching and finding and trying to find
a way to make it better
uh but is kind of like
it's very hard to do it while in flight
and he's under enormous business
pressure too um
so jack dorsey to me is a fascinating
study because i think his mind is in a
lot of good places because he's a good
human being but there's a big titanic
ship that's already moving in one
direction it's hard to know what to do
with that i think that's the story of
twitter i think that's the story of
twitter um one of the things that i
observe is that if you just want to look
at the human side meaning like how are
people being changed how do they feel
what does the culture like
almost all
of the social media platforms that get
big have an initial sort of honeymoon
period where they're actually kind of
sweet and cute yeah like if you look at
the early years of twitter it was really
sweet and cute but also look at snap
tik tok
and then what happens is as they scale
and the algorithms become more
influential instead of just the early
people when it gets when it gets big
enough that it's the algorithm running
it then you start to see the rise of the
paranoid style and then they start to
get dark and we've seen that shift in
tik-tok rather recently but i feel like
that scaling reveals
the flaws within the incentives
i feel like i'm torturing you i'm still
no no it's not torture no because
i i have hope
uh for the world with with humans and
have hope for a lot of things that
humans create including technology and i
just
uh i feel it is possible to create uh
social media platforms that incentivize
different things than the current i
think the current incentivization is
around like the dumbest possible thing
that was invented like 20 years ago or
however long and it just works and so
nobody's changing it i just think that
there could be a lot of innovation for
more see you kind of push back this idea
that we can't know what long-term growth
or happiness is i i if you give control
to people to define what their long-term
happiness and goals are then you that
optimization can happen for each of
those individual people
you know
well i mean
imagine a future
where
probably a lot of people would love to
make their living doing tick-tock dance
videos but people recognize generally
that's kind of hard to get into
nonetheless
dance crews
have an experience that's very similar
to programmers working together on
github so the future is like a cross
between tick tock and github and they
get together and they have their negotia
they have rights they're negotiating
they're negotiating for returns they
join different artists societies in
order to soften the blow of the
randomness of who gets the network
effect benefit because nobody can know
that
and
they uh and i think an individual person
might join a thousand different data
unions in the course of their lives or
maybe even ten thousand i don't know but
the point is that we'll have like these
very hedge distributed portfolios of
different data unions we're part of
and some of them might just trickle in a
little money for
nonsense stuff where we're contributing
to health studies or something and but i
think people will find their way they'll
find their way to the right github-like
community in which they find their value
in the context of supplying
inputs and data and taste and
correctives and all of this into the
algorithms and the robots of the future
and that is a way to resist the uh
the lizard brain based
funding assist mechanisms it's an
alternate economic system that rewards
productivity creativity uh value as
perceived by others it's a genuine
market it's not doled out from a center
there's not some communist person
deciding who's valuable it's actual
market
and the the money is made
by supporting that instead of
just grabbing people's attention in the
cheapest possible way which is
definitely how you get the lizard brain
yeah
okay so we're finally at the agreement
[Laughter]
but i
i just think that
so yeah i'll tell you what how i think
uh
fake social media there's a few things
there's a few things so one i think
people should have complete control over
their data and transparency of uh what
that data is and how it's being used if
they do hand over the control another
thing they should be able to delete walk
away with their data at any moment easy
like with a single click of a button
maybe two buttons i don't know just
easily walk away with their data
uh
the other is control of the algorithm
individualized control of the algorithm
for them
so each one has their own algorithm each
person has their own algorithm they get
to be the decider of uh what they see in
this world and to me that i mean that's
i guess fundamentally decentralized
terms of the key decisions being made
but if that's made transparent i feel
like people will choose that system over
twitter of today over facebook of today
when they have the ability to walk away
to control their data and to control the
kinds of things they see now
let's walk away from the term ai you're
right
in this case you
you have full control of the algorithms
that help you if you want
to use their help but you can also say
fu to those algorithms and just uh
consume the raw beautiful waterfall
of the internet i think that
to me that's not only fixes social media
but i think it will make a lot more
money so i would like to challenge the
idea i know you're not presenting that
but
that the only way to make a ton of money
is to operate like facebook is i think
you can make more money by giving people
control
yeah i mean i certainly believe that
we're definitely in the territory of
uh
wholehearted agreement here
um i i do want to caution against one
thing which is
making a future that benefits
programmers versus p like this idea that
people are in control of their data so
um years ago i co-founded an advisory
board for the eu with a guy named
giovanni but torelli who passed away
it's one of the reasons i wanted to
mention it a remarkable guy
who'd been
he was originally a prosecutor who was
throwing mafioso in jail
in in sicily so he was like this intense
guy who was like i've been i've dealt
with death stress mark zuckerberg
doesn't scare me or whatever so
we worked we worked on this path of
saying let's make it all about
transparency and consent and it was one
of the feeders that led to this huge uh
data
data privacy and and uh protection
framework in europe called the gdpr
and
uh so therefore we've been able to have
uh empirical feedback on how that goes
and the problem is that
most people actually get stymied by the
complexity of that kind of management
they have trouble
and reasonably so i don't i'm like a
techie you know i can i can go in and i
can figure out what's going on but uh i
most people really do and why and so
there's the problem that it
it it
it differentially it differentially
benefits those who kind of have a
technical mindset and can go in and sort
of have a feeling for how this stuff
works
i kind of still want to come back to
incentives and so if the incentive
for whoever is if the commercial
incentive is to help the creative people
of the future make more money because
you get a cut of it
that's how you grow an economy not the
programmers
well some of them will be programmers
it's not anti-programmer i'm just saying
that um it's not only programmers
you know so uh i mean so yeah yeah you
have to make sure the incentives are
right i mean i like
control is an interface problem to where
you have to create something that's
that's uh
compelling to everybody to the creatives
to the public i mean there's uh
i don't know creative commons like the
licensing
uh
this you know there's a bunch of legal
speak just in general the whole legal
profession it's nice when it could be
simplified in the way that you can truly
you know simply understand everybody can
simply understand um
the the basics in the same way
it should be very simple to understand
how the data is being used
and what data is being used for people
but then you're arguing that in order
for that to happen you have to have the
incentives the like
i mean a lot of the reason that money
works
is actually information hiding and
information loss like one of the things
about money is a particular dollar you
get might have passed through your
enemy's hands and you don't know it but
also this is i mean this is what adam
smith if you want to give the most
charitable interpretation possible to
the invisible hand is what he was saying
is that like there's this whole
complicated thing and not only do you
not need to know about it the truth is
you'd never be able to follow it if you
tried and just like let the economic
incentives solve for this whole thing
and and and that um
in a sense every transaction is like a
neuron and a neural net if if he'd had
that metaphor he would have used it
and uh let the whole thing settle to a
solution and don't worry about it um i i
think this idea of
having incentives that reduce complexity
for people can be made to work and and
that's an example of an algorithm that
could be manipulative or not going back
to your question before about can you do
it in a way that's not manipulative and
i would say
um
a github like if you just have this
vision github plus tick tock
combine
is it possible i think it is i'm not
gonna be able to unsee that idea
of creatives on tick tock collaborating
in the same way that people on github
collaborate i like that kind of version
why not i like it i love it i just like
right now when people use by the way
father of teenage daughters
all about tic-tac right
so you know when people use tick-tock
there's a lot of uh
it's kind of funny i was gonna say
cattiness but i was just using the cat
as this exemplar of overcoming
i contradict myself but anyway there's
all this cattiness where people are like
hey this person
and and i i just um
uh what about people getting together in
conjunction saying okay we're gonna work
on this move we're gonna get a bit of
can we get a better musician like and
they they do that but that's the part
that's kind of
off the books right now you know that
should be like right there that should
be the center that's where the that's
the really best part well that's that's
where the invention of get period the
versioning is brilliant and so some of
the some of the things you're talking
about
technology algorithms tools can empower
and that's that's the thing for humans
to to connect to collaborate and so on
can we uh
can we upset more people a little bit
you already i thought maybe we'd have to
try no no can we uh can i ask you
to elaborate because i my intuition was
that you would be a supporter of
something like cryptocurrency and
bitcoin because it is fundamentally
emphasizes decentralization what do you
so can you elaborate
yeah okay look your thoughts on bitcoin
i um
it's kind of funny um i i wrote
i've been advocating some kind of
digital currency for a long time and
when the the uh
when th when bitcoin came out and the
original paper on on blockchain
um my heart kind of sank because i
thought oh my god we're applying all of
this fancy thought and all these very
careful distributed security measures to
recreate the gold standard
like it's just so retro it's so
dysfunctional
it's so useless from an economic point
of view so it's always and then the
other thing is using computational
inefficiency at a boundless scale as
your form of security is a crime against
the atmosphere obviously a lot of people
know that now but we knew that at the
start like the thing is when the first
paper came out i remember a lot of
people saying oh my god i think this
thing scales it's a carbon disaster you
know and and um
i i just like i'm just mystified but
that that's a different question than
when you asked can you have
um a cryptographic currency or at least
some kind of digital currency that's of
a benefit and absolutely like i'm and
there are people who are trying to be
thoughtful about this you should uh if
you haven't you should interview vitalik
buter in some time yeah interviewed him
twice okay so like there are people in
the community who are trying to be
thoughtful and trying to figure out how
to do this better it has nice properties
though right so the one of the nice
problems is that like government
centralized it's hard to control
uh and then the other one to fix some of
the issues that you're referring to i'm
sort of playing devil's advocate here is
you know there's lightning network
there's ideas how to how you uh build
stuff on top of bitcoin similar with
gold that allow you to have this kind of
vibrant economy that operates not on the
blockchain but outside the blockchain
and uses uh bitcoin for uh
for like checking the security of those
transactions so bitcoin's not new it's
been around for a while i've been
watching it closely i've not seen one
example of it creating economic growth
there was this obsession with the idea
that government was the problem that
idea that government's the problem let's
say government earned that wrath
honestly
because if you look at some of the
things that governments have done in
recent decades it's not a pretty story
like
after
after a very small number of people in
the u.s government decided to bomb and
land mine
southeast asia
it's hard to come back and say oh
government's this great thing but
uh then
the problem is that this resistance to
government
is basically resistance to politics it's
a way of saying
if i can get rich nobody should bother
me it's a way of not of not having
obligations to others and that
ultimately is a very suspect motivation
but does that mean
that the impulse that the government um
should not overreach its power is flawed
well i mean what i want to ask you to do
is to replace the word government with
politics
like our politics is people having to
deal with each other
my theory about freedom
is that the only authentic form of
freedom is perpetual annoyance that
all right so
annoyance means you're actually dealing
with people because people are annoying
perpetual means that that annoyance is
survivable so it doesn't destroy us all
so if you have perpetual annoyance then
you have freedom and that's politics
that's politics if you don't have
perpetual annoyance
something's gone very wrong and you
suppress those people it's only
temporary it's going to come back and be
horrible
you should seek perpetual annoyance i'll
invite you to a berkeley city council
meeting so you can know what that feels
like what perfection feels like
but anyway so freedom is being the the
test of freedom is that you're annoyed
by other people if you're not you're not
free if you're not you're trapped in
some temporary illusion that's going to
fall apart
now um the this quest to avoid
government is really a quest to avoid
that political feeling but you have to
have it you have to deal with it
um and it sucks but that's the human
situation that's the human condition and
this idea that we're going to have this
abstract thing that protects us from
having to deal with each other is always
an illusion the idea and i apologize i
uh overstretched the use of the word
government
the idea is there should be some
punishment from the people
when a group when a bureaucracy when a
set of one instead of people or a
particular leader like in an
authoritarian regime which more than
half the world currently lives under if
you
[Music]
like if they become
they start stop representing the people
it stops being like a berkeley uh
meeting and starts being more like uh
like a dictatorial kind of uh situation
and so the point is it it's nice to give
people
uh the populist in decentralized way
power to
um
resist that kind of uh government
becoming over yeah but people see this
idea that the problem is always the
government being powerful is false
the problem can also be criminal gangs
the problem can also be weird cults the
problem can be
abusive um
abusive clergy the problem can be uh
fault infrastructure that fails the
problem can be poisoned water the
problem can be failed electric grids the
problem can be
a crappy education system that makes
this the whole society uh less and less
able to to create value there are all
these other problems that are different
from an overbearing government like you
have to keep some sense of perspective
and not be obsessed with only one kind
of problem because then the others will
pop up but empirically speaking some
problems are bigger than others
so like some
uh like
groups of people like governments or
gangs or companies leaders are you are
you a u.s citizen yes has the government
ever really been a problem for you well
okay so first of all i grew up in the
soviet union used to east well and
actually yeah my wife did too
yeah so i i have i have seen you know um
sure uh
and has the government bothered me i
would say that
uh that's that's a really complicated
question especially because the united
states is such
it's a special place in like like like a
lot of other countries my wife's family
were refused next and so we have like a
very and uh her dad was sent to the
gulag uh for what it's worth uh on my
father's side all but a few were killed
by a pogrom in in uh
a post-soviet program in ukraine
so i i i would think because because you
did a little trick of uh
eloquent trick of language that you
switch to the united states to talk
about government so
i am
i'm i believe unlike my friend michael
malus who's an anarchist i believe
government can do a lot of good in the
world that's exactly what you're saying
which is it's it's politics the thing
that bitcoin folks and cryptocurrency
folks argue is that one of the big ways
that governments can control the
populace is centralized bank like
control the the the money that was the
case in the soviet union too there's
you know uh inflation is can really make
poor people
suffer
and
so what they argue is this is one way to
go around that power that government has
of controlling the monetary system so
that's a way to resist that's not
actually
saying government bad that's saying
some of the ways that
central banks get into trouble can be
resisted through defense so let me ask
you on balance today in the real world
in terms of actual facts
do you think cryptocurrencies are doing
more to prop up corrupt murderous
horrible regimes or to resist those
regimes where do you think the balance
is right now i i know exactly uh having
talked to a lot of cryptocurrency folks
what they would tell me right i
it's hard it's
i don't know no no no no i'm asking it
as a real question there's no way to
know the answer there's no way it can
enhance it perfectly however i gotta say
uh if you look at people who've been
able to decode
uh blockchains and they they do leak a
lot of data they're not as secure as
this widely thought
there are a lot of unknown uh bitcoin
whales from pretty early and they're
huge and
if you ask who are these people um
there's evidence that a lot of them are
quite on not the people you'd want to
support let's say and i i just don't
like i think empirically this idea
that there's some intrinsic way that bad
governments will
be
will will be
disempowered and people will be able to
resist them more then new villains or
even villainous governments will be
empowered there's no basis for that
assertion it just is kind of
circumstantial
and
i think in general
bitcoin ownership
is one thing but bitcoin transactions
have tended to support criminality more
than
productivity of course they would argue
that was that was the story of its early
days that now more and more
bitcoin is being used for uh legitimate
transactions
but that's the difference i didn't say
for legitimate transactions i said for
economic growth for for creativity like
um
i uh i think what's happening is people
are using it a little bit for
for buying i don't know maybe somebody's
companies make it available for this and
that you buy a tesla with it or
something yeah um
investing in a startup hard
it might have happened a little bit but
it's it's not an engine of productivity
creativity and economic growth
whereas old-fashioned currency still is
and
uh anyway i'm look i think something
i'm i'm pro the idea of digital
currencies yeah
i am anti
the idea
of
economics
wiping out politics as a result
i think they have to exist in some
balance to avoid the worst dysfunctions
of each
in some ways there's parallels to our
discussion of algorithms and
cryptocurrency is you're pro the idea
but it can be used
uh to manipulate you can use be used
poorly by
aforementioned humans
well i think that you can make better
designs and worse designs and i think
and you know the thing about
cryptocurrency that's so interesting
is how many of us
are
responsible for the poor designs because
we're all so hooked
on that horatio alger story on like i'm
gonna be the one who gets the viral
benefit you know
way back when all this stuff was
starting i remember it would have been
in the 80s somebody had the idea of
using viral as a metaphor for network
effect
and the whole point was to talk about
how bad network effect was that it
always created distortions that ruined
the the usefulness of economic
incentives that
that created dangerous distortions like
but then somehow even after the pandemic
we think of viral as this good thing
because we imagine ourselves as the
virus right we want to be on the on the
beneficiary side of it but of course
you're not likely to be
there is a sense because money is
involved people are not reasoning
uh clearly always because they want to
be
they want to be part of that first viral
wave that makes them rich and that
blinds people from their basic morality
i had an interesting conversation i
don't i sort of feel like i should
respect some people's privacy but some
of the initial people who started uh
bitcoin i i remember having an argument
about like it's intrinsically a ponzi
scheme like you know the early people
have more than the later people and the
further down the chain you get the more
you're subject to gambling like dynamics
where it's more and more random and more
and more subject to weird network
effects and whatnot unless you're a very
small player uh perhaps and you're just
buying something but even then you'll be
subject to fluctuations because the
whole thing is just kind of it like that
as it fluctuates it's gonna wave around
the little people more and
they i remember the conversation turned
to gambling because gambling's a pretty
large economic sector and it's always
struck me as being
non-productive like somebody goes to las
vegas and loses money and
so one argument is well they got
entertainment they paid for
entertainment as they lost money so
that's fine and the in las vegas does up
the losing of money in an entertaining
way so why not it's like going to a show
so that's one argument
the argument that was made to me was
different from that it's that no what
they're doing is they're getting a
chance to experience hope and a lot of
people don't get that chance and so
that's really worth it even if they're
going to lose they have that moment of
hope and they need to be able to
experience that
and this is a very interesting argument
um that's so heartbreaking because uh
well
i've seen it but i've seen that like
that i have that a little bit of a sense
i've talked to some young people who
invest in cryptocurrency
and it
what i see is this hope this is the
first thing that gave him hope and
that's so heartbreaking to me
that you've gotten hope from the so much
is invested it's like hope from
somehow becoming rich as opposed to
something to me i apologize but money
is in the long term not going to be a
source of that deep meaning it's good to
have enough money but it should not be
the source of hope
and it's heartbreaking to me how many
people is the source of hope
yeah um
you've just described the psychology of
virality or the psychology of
of trying to base a civilization on
semi-random occurrences of network
effect peaks
yeah and
it doesn't really work i mean i think we
need to get away from that we need to
soften those peaks
um
and accept microsoft which deserves
every penny but in every other case
well you mentioned
github i think what microsoft did with
github was brilliant i i was very
okay uh if i can give a uh
not a critical but sure
on microsoft
because they recently purchased bethesda
so elder scrolls is in their hands
i'm watching you microsoft did not screw
up my favorite game so um yeah
look i'm i'm not speaking for microsoft
i haven't i have an explicit arrangement
with them where i don't speak for them
obviously like that should be very clear
i do not speak for them
um i i am not saying um i like them i
think such is amazing um
the term data dignity was coined by
sacha
like so you know we have
uh it's it's kind of extraordinary but
you know microsoft's this giant thing
it's going to screw up this or that you
know it's not it's not
i don't know it's kind of interesting
i've had a few occasions in my life to
see how things
work from the inside of some big thing
and you know it's always just people
kind of
it it's
i don't know there's always like
coordination problems and there's also
there's always there's human problems oh
there's some good people there's some
bad people it's always i hope microsoft
doesn't screw up
and i hope they bring cliffy back you
should never kill clippy bring clippy
back oh clippy but clippy pronounced the
myth of a.i
well that's why this how about i think
you're wrong how about if we all right
could we bring back bob instead of
clippy which one was bob oh bob was
another thing like bob was this other
screen character who was supposed to be
the voice of ai cortana cortana with
cortana dude for you cortana is too
corporate
i like it
there's a there's a woman in seattle
who's like the model for cortana did
cortana's voice and was it there was
like no the way this is great we had a
vis we had her as a she used to walk
around and if you were wearing hololens
for a bit i don't think that's happening
anymore i think i don't think you should
turn a software software into a creature
i think well you you and i yeah just get
a camera tonight you and i well get go
get a dog get a dog
yeah
yeah you're a hedgehog yeah hedgehog
yeah i you co-authored a paper you
mentioned lee smolin
uh titled the
autodidactic universe
which describes our universe as one that
learns its own physical laws
that's a trippy and beautiful and
powerful idea
what are what would you say are the key
ideas in this paper ah okay well i
should say uh
that paper reflected work from last year
and the project the program has moved
quite a lot so it's a little there's a
lot of stuff that's not published that
i'm quite excited about so i have to
kind of keep my frame in that in that uh
last year's thing so i have to try to be
a little careful about that
we can think about it in a few different
ways um
the core of the paper the the technical
core of it is a triple correspondence
one part of it was
already established and then another
part is in the process the part that was
established was
of course understanding different
theories of physics as matrix models the
part that
was uh
fresher is understanding those as a
machining machine learning system so
that we could move fluidly between these
different ways of describing systems and
the reason to want to do that is to just
have more tools and more options because
uh well theoretical physics is really
hard and a lot of programs have kind of
um
run into a state where they feel a
little stalled i guess i can i i want to
be delicate about this because i'm not a
physicist i'm the computer scientist
collaborating so
um i don't mean to diss anybody's so
this is almost like gives a framework
for generating new ideas in physics as
you as we start to publish more about
where it's gone i think you'll start to
see there's there's tools
and ways of thinking about
theories that
i think open up some new paths uh that
that will be of interest um
there's the technical core of it which
is this idea this idea of a
correspondence to give you more facility
but then there's also the storytelling
part of it and this is something
um
lee loves stories and i do and the idea
here is that
a typical
way of thinking about physics is that
there's some kind of starting condition
and then there's some principle by which
the starting
condition evolves
uh and the question is like why the
starting condition like how how
oh the starting condition has to get
kind of per this has to be fine-tuned
and all these things about it have to be
kind of
perfect and so we were thinking well
look what if
we could push the storytelling about
where the universe comes from much
further back by starting with really
simple things that evolve and then
through that evolution explain how
things got to be how they are through
very simple principles right and so
we've been um exploring a variety of
ways to push the the start of the
storytelling further and further back
which um and it's an interesting
it's really kind of interesting because
like uh
um for all of his lee is uh sometimes
considered to be
uh
to have a radical quality in the physics
world but um
uh he still is like no this is gonna be
like the kind of time we're talking
about in which evolution happens is the
same time we're now and we're talking
about something that starts
and continues and i'm like well what if
there's some other kind of time that's
time-like and well that sounds like
metaphysics but
there's an ambiguity you know like
it has to start from something and uh
it's kind of an interesting so there's
this uh
a lot of the math can be thought of
either way which is kind of interesting
so it pushes so far back that basically
all the things we take for granted and
physics start becoming and emerge
i really want to emphasize it's all
super baby steps i don't want to over
claim it's like it's i i think a lot of
the things we're doing we're approaching
some old problems in a in a pretty fresh
way informed there's been a zillion
papers about how you can think of the
universe as a big neural net or how you
can think of different ideas in physics
as being quite similar to or even
equivalent to some of the ideas in
machine learning
and uh
that actually works out crazy well like
i mean it that is actually kind of eerie
when you look at it like uh
there's probably
two or three dozen papers that have this
quality and some of them are just crazy
good and it's very it's very interesting
what we're trying to do is is
take those kinds of observations and
turn them into an actionable framework
where you can then start to
do things with landscapes or theories
that you couldn't do before and that
sort of thing
so in that context
or maybe beyond uh how do you explain us
humans how unlikely are we this
intelligent civilization or is there a
lot of others or are we alone in this
universe
yeah
you seem to appreciate humans very much
i've grown fond of us
um whatever there are nice qualities
um
and like i like that i mean we're kind
of weird we sprout this hair on our
heads and then i don't know we're sort
of weird animals that's the feature not
a bug i think
the weirdness
i hope so i hope so
um
i
i think if i'm just going to answer you
in terms of um truth the first thing i'd
say is we're not we're not
in a privileged enough position
at least as yet to really know much
about
who we are how we are
what we're really like in the context of
something larger what that context is
like all that stuff
we might learn more in the future our
descendants might learn more but we
don't really know very much yeah which
you can either view as frustrating or
charming like that first year of tick
tock or something
um
but all roads lead back to tig talk i
like it well lately uh but but in terms
of there's another level at which i can
think about it where
i sometimes think that
if you
are just
quiet and you do something that gets you
in touch with the way reality happens
and for me it's playing music
sometimes
it seems like you can feel a bit of how
the universe is and it feels like
there's a lot more going on in it and
there is a lot more life and a lot more
stuff happening
and a lot more stuff flowing through i
don't know i'm not speaking as a
scientist now this is kind of a more
my artist's side talking and it's uh
uh so i feel like i'm suddenly in
multiple personalities with you but well
uh kerouac jack kerouac said that uh
music is the only truth
what do you uh it sounds like you might
be at least in part there's a there's a
passage in kerouac's book dr sachs where
somebody tries to just explain the whole
situation with reality and people in
like a paragraph and i i couldn't
reproduce it for you here but it's like
yeah like there are these bulbous things
that walk around and they make these
sounds you can sort of understand them
but only kind of and then there's like
this it's just like this amazing like
just really quick like if if some
spirit being or something was gonna show
up in our reality and hadn't knew
nothing about it it's like a little
basic intro like okay here's what's
going on here
an incredible passage yeah yeah it's
like a one or two sentence summary uh
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy right
of what this uh mostly harmless mostly
harmless yeah do you think there's truth
to that that uh music somehow connects
something that words cannot
yeah music is something that
just towers above me i don't i don't
i don't feel like i have an overview of
it it's just the reverse i don't i don't
fully understand it because on one level
it's simple like you can say oh it's
it's
a thing people evolved to coordinate our
brains on a
pattern level or
or something like that there's all these
things you can say about music which you
know some of that's probably true
it's
also
there's kind of like this
this is the mystery of meaning like
there's a way that just
instead of just being pure abstraction
music can have like this kind of
substantiality to it
that is philosophically impossible
i don't know what to do with it yeah the
amount of understanding i feel i have
when i
hear the right song
at the right time
is not comparable to
anything i can read on wikipedia
anything i can understand
read through in language there's the
music does connect us to something
there's this thing there yeah there's
there's there's some kind of a thing in
it and i've never ever
i i've run across a lot of explanations
from all kinds of interesting people uh
like that it's some kind of uh
a flow language between people or
between people and how they perceive and
and that kind of thing there's
and and that
sort of explanation is fine but it's not
it's not quite it either yeah there's a
there's something about music that makes
me uh believe that pan psychism could
possibly be true
which is uh that everything in the
universe is conscious it makes me think
makes me be humble in how
much or how little i understand about
the functions of our universe
that everything might be conscious
most people um interested in theoretical
physics eventually land in pan psychism
um
but i i'm not one of them i uh
i still think there's this um
pragmatic imperative to
uh
treat people is special so i will
proudly be a dualist
sure uh without people on cats people
and cats yeah i'm not i'm not
i'm not quite sure where to draw the
line or why the line's there or anything
like that but i don't think i should be
required to all the same questions are
equally mysterious for no line so i
don't i'm not i don't feel disadvantaged
by that so i shall remain a duelist but
if you
listen to anyone trying to explain
where consciousness is in a dualistic
sense either believing in souls or some
special thing in the brain or something
you pretty much say
screw this i'm going to be advanced
fair enough
is there moments in your life that
happen
that we're defining in the way that
you hope others your daughter well
listen i gotta say
the moments that defined me were not the
good ones the moments that defined me
were often horrible
um
i um i've had
successes you know but if you ask what
defined me
my mother's death
um
being under the world trade center in
the attack
the things that the things that have had
an effect on me were the most were sort
of real world
terrible things which i don't wish on
young people at all
um and this is this is the thing that's
hard about giving advice to young people
that
they have to learn their own lessons
and
lessons don't come easily
and a world
which avoids hard lessons is will be a
stupid world you know and i i don't know
what to do with it that's a that's a
little bundle of truth that has a bit of
a fatalistic quality to it but i don't i
don't
this is like what i'm saying that you
know freedom equals eternal annoyance
like you can't
like
um there's a degree to which honest
advice
is
not that pleasant to give
and
i i don't want young people to have to
know about everything i think you don't
want to wish hardship on them yeah i
think they they deserve to have
a little grace period of naivete that's
pleasant i i mean i i do you know if
it's possible if it's
ah these things are this is like this is
tricky stuff i mean um
if you if you
okay so let me let me try a little bit
on this advice thing i think one thing
any serious broad advice will have been
given a thousand times before for a
thousand years so this i'm not gonna
i'm not going to claim originality but
i think trying to find a
way to really pay attention
to what you're feeling fundamentally
what your sense of the world is what
your intuition is if you feel like an
intuitive person what you're
um
like like to try to
escape the constant sway of social
perception or manipulation whatever you
wish not to escape it entirely that
would be horrible but to to find
to find cover from it once in a while
to find a sense of being anchored in
that
to believe and experience as a real
thing believing in experience as a real
thing is very dualistic that goes in
that goes with my philosophy of dualism
i believe there's something magical and
i instead of squirting the magic dust on
the programs i think
experience is something real and
something apart something mystical and
your own personal
internal experience that you just have
and then you're saying yeah silence the
rest of the world enough to hear that
like whatever that
magic just yeah and that experience find
with with what is there
and um
i think uh that's one that's one thing
another thing
is to recognize
that kindness
requires genius that it's actually
really hard
that facile kindness is not kindness and
that it'll take you a while to have the
skills
to have kind impulses to want to be kind
you can have right away
to be effectively kind is hard
to be effectively kind it takes it takes
skill it takes
it takes hard lessons
um
it's it's uh you'll never be perfect at
it
to the degree you get anywhere with it
it's the most rewarding thing ever
um
uh let's see what else would i say
i would say um when you're young
you can be very overwhelmed
by social and interpersonal emotions
you'll have
broken hearts and jealousies you'll feel
socially
down the ladder instead of up the ladder
it feels horrible when that happens all
of these things
and you have to remember
what a fragile crust all that stuff is
and it's hard because right when it's
happening it's just so intense
and
if i was actually giving this advice to
my daughter she'd already be out of the
room
so i'm just this is for some like
hypothetical yeah teenager that doesn't
really exist that really wants to sit
and and listen to my wife or your
daughter ten years from now
maybe
a difficult question yeah sure you uh
you talked about losing your mom yeah
uh do you
do you miss her
yeah i mean i still connected her
through music she was a
she was a
young prodigy
piano
player in vienna and uh she survived the
concentration camp and then died in a
car accident
here in the us
what music makes you think of her is
there
is there a song
well she you know she was in vienna so
she's she
had the whole viennese
music thing going um
which is this you know incredible school
of uh
absolute skill and romance bundled
together and uh wonderful on the piano
especially i learned to play the some of
the beethoven sonatas for her and i
played them in this exaggerated drippy
way i remember when i was a kid and uh
exaggerating meaning uh too full of
emotion yeah like just like
it's just it's not the only way to play
beethoven i mean i would i didn't know
there's anything that's a reasonable
question i mean the fashion these days
is to be slightly apollonian with even
with beethoven but
one imagines that
actual beethoven playing might have been
different i don't know i um
i've gotten to play a few instruments he
played and tried to see if i could feel
anything about how it might have been
for him i don't know really
i was always against the clinical
precision of classical music
i thought
a great piano player should be um
like um
in in pain like
you know like emote emotion emotionally
like truly feel the music and and make
it messy sort of sure um maybe play
classical music the way i don't know
blues pianist plays blues
like
it seems like they actually got happier
and i'm not sure if beethoven got
happier i think it's a different i think
it's a different
kind of concept of the place of music
i think the uh
the blues the whole african-american
tradition was initially surviving awful
awful circumstances so you could say you
know there was some of that in the
concentration camps and all that too um
and
it's it's not that beethoven's
circumstances were brilliant but he kind
of also
i don't know this is hard like i mean it
would seem to be his misery was somewhat
self-imposed maybe through i don't i
don't know it's kind of interesting like
um i've known some people who loathed
beethoven like uh the composer uh late
composer pauline oliveros this wonderful
modernist composer i played in a in her
band for a while and she was like oh
beethoven like that's the worst music
ever it's like all ego it completely it
turns um it turns information and i mean
it turns emotion into your enemy and
it's uh it's ultimately um all about
your own self-importance which is all
which has to be at the expense of others
could what else what else could it be
and uh blah blah blah so she had i
shouldn't say i don't mean to be
dismissed but i'm just saying like her
position on beethoven
was very negative and very unimpressed
which is really interesting for the man
or the music
i think uh i don't know i mean he's not
here to speak for herself so it's a
little hard for me to answer that
question i'm um but it was interesting
because i'd always thought it paid homes
like oh you know this is like you know
it is like really the the the dude you
know and she's like yeah you know
beethoven schmidt oven you know it's
like not really happening yeah i still
even though it's cliche i like playing
uh personally just for myself mulan
sonata i mean i just
um moonlight's amazing you know um
i
you know you're talking about comparing
the blues and that sensibility from
europe it's so diff so different in so
many ways i one of the musicians i play
with is uh john bautiste who has the
band on on colbert show and uh he'll
he'll sit there playing jazz and
suddenly go into moonlight he loves
moonlight and what's kind of interesting
is
he's found a way to do beethoven and he
by the way he can really do beethoven
like he uh he went through juilliard and
one time you know what what time he's at
my house he's saying hey do you have the
book of beethoven's house to say yeah i
want to find one i haven't played any
sight read through the whole damn thing
perfectly and i'm like oh god i just
yeah get out of here i don't i can't
even deal with this but anyway
yeah but anyway the thing is he he has
this way
of with the same persona and the same
philosophy moving from the blues and to
beethoven that's really really
fascinating to me it's like um
i don't want to say he plays it as if it
were jazz but he kind of does yeah it's
kind of really and he talks he'll well
he was sight reasoning he talks like
beethoven's talking to him like he's
like oh yeah i hear he's doing this he's
i can't do john but you know it's like
it's really it's really interesting like
it's very different like for me
i was introduced to beethoven as like
almost like this god-like figure figure
and i presume pauline was too that was
really kind of oppressed and hard to
deal with and for him it's just like
it's a conversation
he's playing uh james p johnson or
something it's like another musician who
did something and they're talking and
it's it's very cool to be around it's
very uh
kind of uh
freeing to see someone have that that
abil that that relationship i would love
to hear him play bad horn that sounds
that sounds amazing he's great
we talked about ernest becker
and uh the the
how much value he puts on our mortality
and
our denial of our mortality do you think
about your mortality do you think about
your own death you know what's funny is
i used to not be able to but as you get
older you just know people who die and
there's all these things it just becomes
familiar and and more of a
more ordinary which is what it is
but
are you afraid
um sure
although less so
um
and it's not like i didn't have some
kind of
insight or revelation to become less
afraid i think i just
like i say it's kind of familiarity
it's just knowing people who who have
died and
i really believe
in the future i have this optimism that
people or this whole thing of life on
earth this whole thing we're part of i
don't know where to draw that circle but
this thing is
going somewhere and has some kind of
value and
you can't both believe in the future and
want to live forever you have to make
room for it you know like you have to
that optimism has to also come with its
own like humility you have to make
yourself small to believe in the future
and so it actually in a funny way
comforts me
wow that's powerful
and optimism
requires you to kind of step down after
time
yeah i mean and that said life seems
kind of short but you know whatever
do you think there i've tried to find i
can't find the complaint department you
know i really want to i want to bring
this up but the customer service number
never answers and like the email bounces
one way
uh do you think there's meaning to it
to life
ah well see um
meaning's a funny word like we say all
these things as if we know what they
mean but meaning
we don't know what we mean when we say
meaning like we obviously do not and uh
it's a it's it's a funny little mystical
thing i think it ultimately connects to
that sense of experience that dualists
uh tend to believe in
um
because there are why like if you look
up to the stars and you experience that
awe inspiring like joy
whatever
when you look up to the stars i i don't
know like for me this kind of makes me
feel
uh joyful maybe a little bit melancholy
just some weird soup of feelings
and ultimately the question is like why
are we here in this vast universe
that question why
have you been able in some way
maybe through music answer it for
yourself
my impulse
is to feel like it's not quite the right
question to ask but i feel like going
then that down that path is just too
tedious for the moment and i don't want
to do it but
the wrong question well just because you
know
um i don't know what meaning is and i i
think um i do know that sense of awe
i grew up in southern new mexico and the
stars were so vivid um
i had i've had some
weird misfortunes
but i've had some weird
luck also one of our near neighbors uh
was the head of optics research at white
sands and when he was young he
discovered pluto his name was clyde
tombaugh
and uh he taught me how to make
telescopes grinding mirrors and stuff
and my dad had also made telescopes when
he was a kid but uh clyde had like
backyard telescopes that would put to
shame a lot of like i mean he really he
did his telescopes you know and so i
remember
he'd let me go and play with him and
just like looking at a
globular cluster and you're seeing the
actual photons and with a good telescope
it's really like this object like you
can really tell
this isn't coming through some
intervening information structure this
is like the actual photons and it's
really a three-dimensional object
and you have even a feeling for the
vastness of it and um
it's it's
it's i don't know so i definitely i was
very very fortunate
to have a connection to this guy that
way
when i was a kid um to have had that
experience again the emphasis yeah
experience i um
it's kind of funny like i
i feel like sometimes like i've taken um
when she was younger i took my daughter
and her friends to to like a telescope
there are a few around here that are
kids can go and use and they would like
look at jupiter's moons or something i
think like galilean moons and i i don't
know if they quite
had that because it's like too
it's been just too normalized and i
think maybe
when i was growing up screens weren't
that common yet and maybe it's like too
confusable with the screen i don't know
you know somebody uh uh
brought up in conversation to me
somewhere i don't remember who but they
they kind of posited this idea that
if humans early humans weren't able to
see the stars like if earth atmosphere
was such there was cloudy
that we would not develop human
civilization there's something about
being able to look up
and see a vast
universe is like that's fundamental to
the development of human civilization
i thought that was a curious kind of
thought
that reminds me of that uh
old isaac asimov story where the cl you
know there's this planet where they
finally get to see what's in the sky
once in a while and it turns out they're
in the middle of a globular cluster and
they're always starting
i forget what happens exactly god that's
that's from when i was the same age as a
kid i don't really remember yeah
uh but um yeah i don't know it's uh
it might be right i'm just thinking of
all the civilizations that grew up under
clouds i mean like the
the vikings needed a special uh
diffracting piece of mica to navigate
because they could never see the sun
they had this thing called a sunstone
that they found from this this one cave
do you know about that so they were in
this like
uh they were trying to navigate boats
you know in the north atlantic with
without being able to see the sun
because it was cloudy and so they they
used uh a
uh
uh
chunk of mica to diffract it in order to
be able to align where the sun really
was because they couldn't tell my eye
and navigate so i'm just saying there
are a lot of civilizations that are
pretty impressive that have to deal with
a lot of clouds
uh
the amazonians invented our agriculture
and they they were probably under clouds
a lot i don't know i don't know to me
personally the the question of the
meaning of life
becomes most um
vibrant most apparent when you look up
at the stars because
it makes me feel very small
that we're not small
but then you ask
it it still feels that we're special
and then the natural question is like
well if we are special as i think we are
why the heck are we here
in this vast universe
that ultimately is the question of um
right well the meaning of life i mean
look
there's a confusion sometimes in trying
to use
uh
to set up a question
or a thought experiment or something
that's defined in terms of a context to
explain something where there is no
larger context and that's a category
error
if we want to do it in physics
or well right in computer science
it's hard to talk about the universe as
a turing machine because a turing
machine has an external clock and an
observer and uh input and output there's
a larger context implied in order for it
to be defined at all
and so if you're talking about the
universe you can't talk about it
coherently as a turing machine
quantum mechanics like that quantum
mechanics has an external clock and has
some kind of external context depending
on your interpretation
um
that's either you know the observer or
whatever
and there's a they're they're similar
that way so maybe maybe turing machines
and quantum mechanics can be
better friends or something because they
have a similar setup but the thing is if
you have something that's defined
in terms of an outer context
you can't talk about ultimates with it
because obviously it doesn't it's not
suited for that so there's some ideas
that are their own context general
relativity is its own context it's
different that's why it's hard to unify
and
i think the same thing is true when we
talk about
these types of questions like
uh
meaning
is in a context and
to talk about ultimate meaning is
therefore a category or it's not it's
not a
um
it's not a resolvable way of thinking it
might be a way of thinking that
is experientially
um or aesthetically valuable because
it is
awesome in the sense of you know
awe-inspiring um
but to try to treat it analytically is
not
sensible maybe that's what music and
poetry are for yeah maybe i think so i
think music actually does escape any
particular context that's how it feels
to me but i'm not sure about that that's
once again crazy artists talking not
scientists
well you did uh you do both masterfully
uh jaren and like i said i'm a big fan
of everything you've done of you as a
human being um i appreciate the the fun
argument we had today that will i'm sure
continue for 30 years as it did with
mark minsky
um honestly i i deeply appreciate that
you spend your really valuable time with
me today it was a really great
conversation thank you so much
thanks for listening to this
conversation with jaren lanier
to support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from jaron lanier himself
a real friendship ought to introduce
each person to unexpected weirdness in
the other
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time